-Our first guest
is an Emmy-nominated actress
starring in the hit series
"WandaVision,"
which is available
on Disney Plus.
Here is Kathryn Hahn!
Kathryn Hahn! Ah, look.
Come on, now.
That's what I'm talking about.
Kathryn, welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
I appreciate you being here.
-I am so happy to be back,
my friend.
How are you doing?
-You are the best.
I'm fantastic.
I'm happy to see you.
Mwah, mwah, mwah.
I wanted to thank you for --
for doing that bit with us.
We did "FallonVision,"
the spoofing "WandaVision."
You were so great.
Thank you for doing that.
I --
-How good was that whole thing?!
I'm so impressed!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And Lizzie? It was so good!
And Lizzie did it from her,
like, hotel room or whatever?
-Yeah, she was in London.
Elizabeth was in London.
I don't know where you were, but
last time you were on our show,
by the way, you were nice to me.
You came on our show when
we were doing the show from home
and no one knew
what was going on.
And thank you for doing that.
-Yes.
-I believe you were
in your garage.
-No, I was in my un-air --
yes, a very hot,
un-air-conditioned garage,
and I thought I had done it okay
with a self-style.
And then after
the segment aired,
I saw -- I started to get texts
from pals being like,
"Honey, what -- what's --
what happened to your hair?"
And then when I looked
at it again,
it really did look like my hair
got caught in a ceiling fan
from behind.
So, clearly, I can't
do my own hair, you guys.
It was a rat's nest.
-I don't know if this is
that bad, to be honest.
-Oh, come on!
-No, I think it's --
I think you look pretty --
I think you look --
I think you look gorgeous.
-That's very kind.
It looks like a horse tail.
That is very, very kind.
You and --
I remember David Spade was on,
and you and Spade
were yukking it up.
And as the humidity
was happening,
my hair just kept going like
[Groaning]
And then it was like,
"And 5, 4, 3, 2, and disaster."
-Oh, my God. No, no.
-But it was fun.
We got through it.
-You're a knockout.
You're a knockout, buddy.
-Oh. Tell me more.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
I want to talk to you
about "WandaVision,"
because it was the biggest hit
in the entire world.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Couldn't have been bigger,
and we all needed it.
Everyone was at home.
We needed something --
And you're so good.
You couldn't tell me anything.
And we didn't know --
It was all you the whole time.
-I couldn't tell you anything.
And I'm telling you,
it was every single time
I had to do an interview,
it was like I had to say
a silent prayer,
because Agnes and Agatha
were just a couple letters off.
And I just thought, if I slip,
it's going to be --
It's going to be not fun for me,
for my family, or my legacy.
-But you pulled it off.
You pulled off
the biggest switcheroo ever.
No one saw it coming.
The Internet broke.
It was fantastic to watch.
It was a TV moment.
It was a pop culture moment.
What's it like being
in the Marvel Universe
and having --
being part of that?
-It's bananas! I --
I never saw this
in my -- my future.
But to be this part
in this -- in this world
with those delicious humans --
I mean, you know Lizzie.
She's a gem and a half.
It's been -- It's so fun.
Yeah, the best. And to play
a witch? Forget it. The best.
-Yeah. You're getting crazy
awards buzz
and well -- well-deserved,
as well.
Do your -- Do your kids
think it's cool?
Are they old enough?
-I mean, I -- They will
never think I'm cool.
Like, I am so embarrassing
to them at all times
to the point that they will
not let me finish a sentence
without being like,
"Mom, like, please. Don't."
Like, they can't even --
They look at me like
I can't do anything right
right now.
I mean they're, you know,
teenagers and pre-teenagers.
So I'm not -- you know,
I'm never going to be cool.
-Well, you actually
sent me a thing,
which is very nice of you.
You sent me a note
that your daughter wrote to you?
-Yeah, this is true.
-Look at this.
-That is pretty cute, guys.
This is at the finale.
-"Dear Mom, congrats!
You were such a bad-ass.
We love you,
and we're so proud of you.
XOXO. P.S. Sleep well."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on. That's not bad.
-She -- That was after
seeing the finale.
So, yes, you're right. That was
very cute, language aside.
In that -- In that letter,
it was appropriate.
-Language aside, yeah.
But also, you got a #1 song
in the iTunes chart
out of "WandaVision."
"Agatha --"
Someone's going nuts here --
"Agatha All Along" went to #1
on iTunes on the charts
'cause that was your song
that you sang,
and you knocked it
out of the park.
Were you nervous to sing it?
-I mean, apparently over Biebs.
I was like, "What is happening?"
Like, I was --
-Biebs!
-I mean -- The Biebs!
Sorry, Biebs.
I can't -- I'm sorry, Biebs.
I can't help you.
[ Laughter ]
-You are the best.
"Sorry, Biebs,
I can't help you."
Congrats on the success
of "WandaVision."
You crush it, as you always do.
I want to show everyone
part of the scene
featuring the song
"Agatha All Along."
Here's Kathryn Hahn
in "WandaVision." Take a look.
-♪ It's been Agatha all along ♪
♪♪
-♪ She's insidious ♪
-Ha-ha!
-♪ So perfidious ♪
♪ That you haven't even noticed,
and the pity is ♪
-♪ The pity is ♪
-♪ Pity, pity, pity, pity ♪
♪♪
♪ It's too late
to fix anything ♪
♪ Now that everything
has gone wrong ♪
♪ Thanks to Agatha ♪
-Ha!
-♪ Naughty Agatha ♪
-♪ It's been Agatha all along ♪
[ Gasps ]
And I killed Sparky, too.
[ Laughing ]
-Come on, dude!
You were brilliant!
It was so great!
I love you did that.
Kathryn Hahn, everybody.
Check out "WandaVision"
on Disney Plus.